HELEN ARNEY: (SINGING) There
are ways to waste your time
until departure.
Like playing golf or reading
Jeffrey Archer.
Some people spend some proper
afternoons on Wagner opera.
But Friday by Rebecca Black
is three minutes
you won't get back.
So I have tried to write a song
that set a record for how
long a song can possibly
go on.
Are you ready, Matt?
It goes, 1,
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
That's right, let's
do it again.
Come on.
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
you can sing along,
if you like.
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
although not if you're
in a library
or on public transport.
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
We need to get a few
more of these done.
How about we do three
harmonies.
That way we'll get it
down a lot quicker.
All right, here we go.
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
MATT PARKER: Nearly, hang on.
Hang on.
Phew.
HELEN ARNEY: (SINGING) Well
bang the drum and play the
victory bugle.
What you did just there
is sing a Googol.
One a hundred big fat zeros.
But yourself a drink,
you hero.
Well, why complete this
pointless task?
Well now, you're ready for
the advanced class.
The next idea is more complex.
It's the ultimate time
waster's test.
We'll tried to sing
a Googolplex.
It's going to take
a bit longer.
1, [SINGING GOOGOLPLEX SONG]
come on, everyone.
[SINGING GOOGOL SONG]
Why are you not doing
it, Matt?
[SINGING GOOGOLPLEX SONG]
MATT PARKER: We're not
going to make it.
HELEN ARNEY: Matt, I thought
you liked math.
Seriously.
Why are you carrying on?
MATT PARKER: Because look, we
managed just, eventually, to
get 100 zeroes.
But a googol of zeroes-- there's
no way we're going to
get a googol of zeroes
on this board.
In fact, even if every single
subscriber to Numberphile, if
they were all singing
along, which,
believe me, they're not.
But if the approximately half
a million subscribers, so
that's 5 times 10 to the 5, if
they all joined in, and they
did 100 each, times 10 to the
2, then that's only going to
be 5 times 10 to the 7.
We will have hit 5, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
That's half a million people.
HELEN ARNEY: That's rubbish.
MATT PARKER: It's accurate.
HELEN ARNEY: All right, let's
try a few other things.
Let's say that we're singing
about what 1.5 0's per second.
And I think we can recruit
everyone alive
on Earth right now.
All of you Numberphiles,
get hold of
everyone alive on Earth.
It's about 7 billion
people, right?
MATT PARKER: Yeah.
HELEN ARNEY: And how about we
have been singing since the
dawn of time.
How about we do that.
So that's about [INAUDIBLE]
billion years.
Can you do that in seconds
for me, Matt?
MATT PARKER: It's round about 3
times 10 to the 17 seconds.
HELEN ARNEY: OK, that's good.
That's getting a good
number up now.
So now we want to do
some more 0's.
So how about we do want my old
music teacher used to suggest.
She used to say sing with
every cell in your body.
So that's 75 trillion cells.
So pop that in as well.
That's it, good.
All right, now that should be
getting somewhere near a
googolplex.
That's what we're aiming for.
That's what we're going
to be near.
MATT PARKER: OK, if we had every
single human singing
with every single cell, that's
3 times 10 to the 41, which
means you're up to around about
10, 20, 30, 41, there.
HELEN ARNEY: That is not bad.
Seriously, that's like half.
I mean, we're halfway there.
If we carry on--
MATT PARKER: No.
HELEN ARNEY: No, we just
need to do double.
No look, Brady, do the ding.
Ding, ding, ding--
[DING]
MATT PARKER: Exactly, right
we're not halfway there.
You don't compare the
size of numbers by
lining up the digits.
It's not a [BLEEP]
sudoku.
What was that ding?
What you do, right,
is you compare the
actual relative sizes.
So just to put into perspective,
if we had every
single human singing with every
single cell of their
body, and let's say a googol
of zeroes, which is what we
have to sing.
Let's say that was the size of
the entire known universe.
And I'm using the volume of the
known university, not the
mass, because I just haven't
got a [BLEEP]
clue what the mass is.
But if the universe was a google
of zeroes, every single
human then sung with every
single cell since the dawn of
time, we will have sung the
proportional volume of that.
It's pretty small.
Volume-wise, it's
incredibly thin.
HELEN ARNEY: Is that is.
MATT PARKER: That's it.
That's every single human,
every single
cell, dawn of time.
And everything else
in existence
is the entire googol.
HELEN ARNEY: Well, that
is disappointing.
MATT PARKER: It's accurate.
HELEN ARNEY: Well, what I've
learned today is that (SING) I
can sing a googol, sing a
googol, but not a googolplex.
Good?
Happy day?